ten it
so ten it's a new film starring
christopher nolan well it's written and
directed by christopher nolan
i just feel like christopher and all the
movies are really christopher nolan's a
star so anyhow it stars john david
washington
robert pattinson and we saw the trailer
right the trailer shows you that they're
looking for
bad guy kenneth brennan there's this
ability to
reverse time is called inversion in
which things go backwards through what
we perceive as time
but it's in there the trailer lied to us
it did which trailers their mouthpieces
for movies they're propaganda it's kind
of like fox news for the right cnn for
the left movie trailers for movies
they're there to convince you that this
thing is going to be the greatest thing
ever so sometimes in movie trailers they
showcase something that really isn't
front and center
for a large section of the movie and
such is the case with
tenant 10 it's essentially a spy movie
like consciously i'm watching the movie
i'm like okay
so this is like christopher nolan does
james bond or any other spy movie new
guy gets recruited there's a bad guy and
he has a
super bad thing that can do a lot of
damage to the world so they got to stop
bad guys this movie's two and a half
hours long it's not like for two and a
half hours you're dealing with good guys
and bad guys
doing inversion going backwards and
forwards and it's not
for the bulk of the movie that's not the
case for the bulk of this movie
you gotta go into this movie being like
okay it's a spy movie and
as a spy movie it was it was fine for a
spy movie bit convoluted in the
beginning like the setup of a movie you
know it's establishing the world the
characters character building
my head was spinning and no it's not
because of inversion funny enough like
this movie
has this high concept of something
called inversion where things go
backwards and
it's like nolan took that he was like
all right i gotta make that accessible
for people watching this movie and he
makes it very understandable
and then simple things like world
building character relations he's like
i'm gonna make that so
[ __ ] complex it's a tangled web of
this person deals with that person but
we gotta get to that person we gotta get
to that person to get to that person but
to get to that person i have to go
through this you gotta break into this
place so it kind of feels like a heist
movie slash spy movie all
in the name of getting to the bad guy it
is possible that the setup of this movie
felt like a
choppy convoluted mess because there was
supposed to be more
information in there because it felt
like he got the nuggets of setup and it
was just moving fast like it wanted to
just
move on if i found out that this two and
a half hour long movie was supposed to
be
a three and a half hour long movie most
of which was in the setup
i wouldn't be too surprised the second
half of this movie
that's where i really started loving it
the last act of this movie was amazing
yeah that that's me saying i was
watching this movie going yeah it's
enjoyable enough spy movie to going holy
[ __ ]
i just love this guy's imagination and i
do i always appreciate that about
christopher nolan in a world where
there's
remakes and prequels and remake wolves
christopher nolan
constantly is like i want to give
something unique
that makes them walk out of the movie
theater feeling like they hadn't
felt something like that before and i
reached that in this movie it's the last
half hour to be honest it's like i was
of two minds in this movie i can't
think recently of a time where i was
sitting there going
it's an enjoyable enough movie too at a
point being like oh that's [ __ ]
amazing and i do want to touch on the
sound mixing of this movie too which i
want to tread lightly on because it
could have just been the movie theater i
watched it in
some drunk projections shows up like
this just turn up the baseball this is
just
[ __ ] up all the sound human beings work
in the projection booth however i ran
into this
with interstellar and the sneak peek of
dark knight rises imac showed the first
five minutes of dark knight rises before
dark knight rises came out and bane's
mask
he sounded like kenny from south park
and so i guess nolan remixed it for the
movie that was coming out
so nolan's known for having some people
come out of movie theaters being like
the way that was mixed was strange and i
kind of ran into that a few times with
this movie like sometimes you have
sound effects in the background you know
ambient noise but it's over
taking some of the voices and you have
some of the music coming on
and when they talk and they're dialogue
and it sounds like this
you know you get to talk to them i feel
like an old man like what do you say
or maybe it's just me maybe i'm just
there but if it's not the movie itself
let's not jump to that conclusion i
still say drunk projectionist if for
nothing else when this movie comes out
on blu-ray i want like
10 hours of making of because the making
of in this movie i'm sure is
so fascinating i want to know more about
it i want to know more of it like that
hallway fight scene alone
it's wild i don't know how they did it
i'd like to i'm intrigued i'm
fascinated so the big enemy in this
movie isn't actually kenneth branagh
it's trailers i just get bummed out when
i think of what the trailer
could have been like if it was just a
christopher nolan film like right there
we're gonna see it anyway and in the
trailer it was like oh this guy gets
recruited something called tenet this
bad guy has a thing and it's a danger to
the world i was like oh it's like
nolan's doing a james bondish thing all
right let's watch this nolan thing
and then in the movie for the first time
you see people starting to go backwards
my brain would have melted but as it
stands the trailer overcooked it showed
too much and just kind of
compromised the experience but in the
end by the end
i enjoyed it it's like the average of
this movie comes down to yeah
enjoyed it has some problems in the
setup not gonna say it doesn't but the
second half
is work it's business but if i bought
this movie on blu-ray i'd probably just
watch the second half i'd watch the [ __ ]
out of that second half but the second
half nonetheless so all in all i felt
ten it was a good time no alcohol
required
i do hope they make a sequel and nolan's
not really known for sequels
other than the batman movies but of the
christopher nolan intellectual property
he doesn't make sequels
but i do hope he makes a sequel to
tenant all right so tenet have you seen
it what did you think about it or what's
your favorite christopher nolan movie
you know what rank have you ranked him
before has the ranking has it shuffled
around as you've gotten older whatever
it is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more